hey guys how are you welcome to a makeup
video I know I know it's quite riveting
I got so many questions from you guys
about what do I use on my face what is
the process that you go through to do
whatever it is you do and for most of my
videos this is my standard go to look
this here this face so this video you're
gonna seem to use a bunch of random
products most of which probably fly by
too quickly that you don't even know
what they are well I'm gonna write a
blog entry up and I list everything that
I used and the link will be in the
description enjoy and let me know what
kind of videos you guys want to see next
let's do it
you
[Music]
thanks for watching I hope you guys
enjoyed like I said at the beginning of
this video a link below somewhere so
find everything that I used on my face
and that's that number just subscribe
and I will see you guys in the next
video good bye next to me is my end of
the world preparation bag I put together
a few things and the only stipulation
was it all has to fit in this bag is
really heavy